everybody of course knows you as Hank
yeah
such an iconic role such a great role
for you and now it seems like you're
doing a 180 because you're playing Ben
Franklin what did you learn about Ben
Franklin the real Ben Frank yeah we're
doing this role cuz you must've done a
lot of research I did it was it was
interesting because Ben isn't the the
Bend that we learned about in high
school yeah at least the Ben that I
looked at when we were studying this
role he was quite the quite the drinker
yeah yeah quite the ladies man yeah he
he's like America's first pop star you
know I'm saying yeah he's like Justin
Bieber but with brains yeah yeah any
roast has started already he he was
incredibly popular he was world famous
in France they uh they treated him like
a god yeah he would show up and if he
wore something they would wear it you
know in France that whole year and he
loved the ladies I read somewhere that
he literally had 15 illegitimate kids
right yeah but this is the stuff they
don't get into when you're in the
seventh grade
that guy was everywhere he had
mistresses he loved the prostitutes you
know he's fair to say that the British
weren't the only ones who were coming
okay now listen
this is what the hell's going on it's
[Laughter]
like a womanizer he was also a Myra he
was a bit of an exhibitionist he was you
liked he liked to let it all hang out
you know including his that's usually
what that means
check out the elbow ladies yeah I'm what
but he would he wasn't afraid to be
naked around people right he would sit
around you sort of like I guess Lyndon
Johnson way he would invite people in
and was in the tub you know or in the
can and yeah and they would sit out on
his patio just all butt-naked yeah yeah
that's the brand that's that's the been
that started our country this is the
word you're trying to get out about Ben
Franklin it was in the script you know
that was kind of what attracted me to
the role that it wasn't just like
there's stodgy you know founding father
he was like this crazy guy so it was fun
to play now any role that has nudity
you'll Dom in yeah right
were you ever groped by Johnny Depp as
Ben Franklin this was shot in Romania in
Romania yeah Romania yeah and you know
you tweeted a picture that I thought was
hilarious this is a real picture you
took in Romania look at that number it's
so hilarious there means 0 for 6 they
have no they don't know about 911 I
guess certainly it was a crazy place
though you know Romania I think it used
to be like the Paris of Eastern Europe
back in the day but then the Communists
came in right so there was all these
like beautiful buildings and there was
like you know communist architecture you
know which probably probably built in
the 40s 50s not so great yeah Nicolae
Ceausescu whatever his name was
you